Donald Trump's sort of newish
spokeswoman Liz Harrington appeared
yesterday on the water cooler on real
America's voice with this guy David
Brody she was asked to comment about uh
Joe Biden's speech and also about the
upcoming midterms and this is a
prototypical example this is the
textbook example of a priori reasoning
okay
forget about everything I just said just
let's listen to the clip and then I'll
explain to you what I mean somehow he
thinks he's going to be this last minute
savior for his party at the last moment
with the midterms why is Biden doing
this tonight Liz
you know that's a very good question
because anyone who knows it's not that
great of a question because he's such a
drag on the Democrat Party in any chance
they have which we know they don't come
next Tuesday they don't have a chance
unless they cheat as you documented very
well there's so many cases already of
just irregularities and misdeeds and
that's not true evidence of the
corruption in our election process and
that's the only hope that they have
because the fact is Democrats do not
like democracy they don't want the
voters to decide they want to decide for
the voters that's not really the way it
went in 2020 is it Liz and look at how
that has worked out they're destroying
the country they've destroyed our border
they've destroyed the economy they
destroyed our energy Independence all of
these things that were so hard fought by
President Donald J Trump to put America
First they're destroying and the voters
know it and they know they're going to
lose come election day unless they do
you know some of these outrageous things
that they did in 2020 and do it on such
a scale that we've never seen before
because they're going to have to
overcome really this Mammoth Red Wave
that's coming yeah this is Red Alert
stuff folks they're doing it again they
are doing the fascist authoritarian
thing if they win then they must have
cheated Democrats that is a priori now a
priori means reasoning which precedes
from a theoretical deduction rather than
from observations or experiences so what
does that mean in this context they're
not observing actual cheating
or waiting until election day to see how
the election goes and then if there
really are irregularities or cheating
then you go oh this is what happened
it's theoretical it's in advance absent
any actual data or empirical reality if
they win they cheated regardless of what
we actually observe and of course they
add on to it another classic
authoritarian wrinkle which is to claim
you observed the thing anyway even
though you didn't uh oh there's already
irregularities the irregularities we're
seeing now are for example armed
individuals hanging around Arizona drop
boxes right Wingers trying to intimidate
voters though the only irregularities
we're seeing are from people on Liz
Harrington's side these folks are
disgusting and they're delusional but
they're dangerous and we've talked about
all of the reasons why and it should
really scare the Daylights out of all of
us because what they tried to do in 2020
they might get close enough in 2022 to
then really be able to do it in 2024.
we'll have all the results but these
folks will say it's rigged if they don't
win and that's really scary the David
packman shows longest running sponsor is
blinkist the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils each of them
down into an explainer you can read or
listen to in 15 minutes blinkist also
condenses episodes of popular podcasts
into 15-minute explainers I've been
using blinkist for years to supplement
the books I read I love reading I I read
all the time but there's even more books
I don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkus premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below